like just ask yourself how often in a
given week or month you encounter
someone and you think to yourself wow
this person really takes pride in their
craft now you do run into people like
that but they always stand out like
shining Diamonds in the Rough because
most people don't take pride in their
craft or really don't have a craft at
all this is the thing underlying the
problem that Dei has made significantly
worse at every turn and why does this
underlying problem exist where is it
coming from that's a whole other
conversation entirely for now the point
is simply that people are demoralized
and checked out